yeah i think we have a quorum uh welcome
back everyone thanks for coming to the
afternoon session so again we have two
sessions so
learning session and then causality
um so
this session we have four talks the
first talk is by richard
all right thank you um
so my name is richard go
i'm a research associate with institute
laboratories university cambridge in the
meantime i'm a research fellow here at
simon's my office 318.
i got my phd in statistics from
university of washington last year and
my thesis was about likelihood analysis
of causal models
and
i do want to say that my hair usually
looks better when i'm on vacation
um so
i just want to you know show you some
pictures and i guess i want to convince
you through an example that the current
methods towards causal discovery whereas
you use some score
and you pick the one well i guess the
score base maybe
you pick the one with the highest score
the type approach can be problematic and
and i'm trying to illustrate it with a
simple example
let's just say look at the simplest
example that we want to choose between
two graphical models
one is the collider model which implies
one and two are marginally independent
the other one is the conditional
independent model
which is you can draw that as a chain
one or fork they're equivalent
uh the conditional independence is one
independent two given three
so assume let's just assume we know one
of them must hold and
the variables are jointly gaussian
now if we take a geometric view of what
the two models they want to select from
well those correspond to algebraic
constraints on the covariance matrix
well it suffices just to look at the
correlations for simplicity right if i
draw the correlations at three axis
one two two one three and two three
the marginal independent model it just
says one or two marginal independence so
this one the row one two axis must
vanish so that's represented by this
great plane
okay the other model condition defense
model
the conditional independence relation
can be written as this
equation if you draw it it's this
checkerboard hyperbolic parabola
so um
when we have sample and one
differentiate between the two models i'm
i'm telling you that this is not always
easy because
they intersect and they intersect you
know uh through the two axes on the
plane and they're further in the sec at
the origin
so basically if you just do a score
based approach you just pick the one
with a higher bic
then when the two when one of the
when you're close to one of the axes you
basically
you know you're as good as flipping a
coin randomly
so uh we can look at the model a little
bit carefully sort of like a ratio test
now basically um there are two different
regimes that makes
is the heart makes it hard to
differentiate between the two one regime
is
you know consider the set of laws that
converge to
a point on the axis
you know and this is kind of the nice
thing nice regime that i would call
because
you know
at the intersection point locally the
two models are as if you are
intersecting two two planes or two lines
and if you're written away from origin
that means they're written away from one
model to the other
um okay so this is the kind of the nice
one but more interesting one is where
you
think about your sampling distribution
is you know in the vicinity of the
origin
now if you do that the strange behavior
is that if you are
rooting away from the origin actually
you get one over n away from one model
to the other
okay what this implies is that even if
your effect size has measured by this
distance from the origins when we're
written
you cannot differentiate between the two
models
okay there is a more uh information
theoretical analysis that basically says
this effect size is controlled by the
product of the two
axes on the plane by the two rows on the
plane where we basically compare this
quantity to whenever root n
so as you all know very well uh you know
like when they are
faster than a root in then
uh it's not distinguishable when they're
asymptotically bigger than rooten
they're distinguishable the interesting
regime is where they are comfortable
with whenever written
well then here comes my criticism with
the type of score based approach
for which the consistency usually relies
on some strong faithfulness assumptions
now suppose i impose strong faithfulness
and say you know to differentiate model
i always bound row away from zero
specifically we want all the rows to be
bounded away from one over root n
but
that means if we our sampling
distribution is in this regime is near
the origin
the distance between models is actually
one over n
right you still cannot differentiate
between these two models even if you
assume the type of strong faithfulness
that seems to bound every row okay
so this is this is a bit like you know
even if you think all the effect sizes
are strong but
the models can be
actually quite
close to each other in this
forest of dax
um
so actually
we developed a proposal that's
less
aggressive in the sense that we allow
a third option when you select between
the two models the third option is being
saying basically saying you know i
cannot differentiate between models in
terms of dag selection that's type of
decision rule that allows you to report
not a single model but a collection of
models
okay and another aspect is that
this decision basically look at the
likelihood ratio test
you know and
compare it with some threshold c alpha
if it is
positive it's bigger than the positive
value of the c alpha you can you can
commit to one model
if it is smaller than negative value of
the same threshold to commit to the
other model anything between i just say
i don't know
um and the c alpha
uh is actually a bit uh
funny as well because
uh i didn't mention but basically the
essential distribution could depend on
how and where
the sample distribution converge to
to the axis or to the origin and also
depends on where uh how it converges
so if you take all those asymptote
distribution and take a proper envelope
then that envelope could be used to
formulate
these critical values that is valid for
all possible regimes
um
so so as i said i'm interested in this
type of problems model selection with
confidence and less stringent stringent
assumptions
um about causal models
there are also some other stuff i'm
interested in like semi-parametric
theory graphical models
and algebraic aspects of graphical
models and we have a weekly reading
group at 1 pm on monday everybody's
welcome i'm also
interested in information theory and
patch identification
okay i want to thank you very much
[Music]
oh yeah
if you're the situation where you can't
choose between these decks
is it the possibility that if you extend
your model class beyond course with
sufficient tags you might be able to
go for something else do you know what i
mean
there's a problem
it it could be that
it could be that yes so
um i guess if you just choose that in
the nested section you wouldn't have
this problem
but if you want choosing models that are
non-nested
then at the intersection they have this
problem
that the local geometry
might not like uh usual euclidean or
normal local geometry and you have this
problem so i'm not sure i think if
you're always comparing to a bigger
model you don't have this problem but
i'm not sure
by introducing more models that would
resolve
decisions
the um
what you said about strong faithfulness
so
in the strong faithfulness setting
you're ruling out that intersection
you're bounding away from it because
at the intersection of those two
independence models you know
faithfulness
have to be some delta away from that
intersection
so i can i wouldn't try i understood
what you've said about right
so strong fifth one is saying you
basically want to bound all the rows you
know non-zero rows away from zero right
but how large is that structure well it
is inherently always compared to the sum
of them and we think usually whatever
root n is the correct sample size right
it should be asymptotically bigger than
whatever we can
but that still does not ensure that
these two models are different are
distinguishable from the channel
i see but if you allow that boundary to
be like a large larger than whatever
root i have yeah then then you have to
basically enumerate all the
possible intersections compute the
curvature and say you know
but the coverage could be pretty high i
mean this is
like square but sometimes it could be
to the higher power so
it makes those assumptions less
possible i would say
thank you
okay